ab so recht also ich meinen er hat
muskeln dazugewonnen und armin laschet
hat leidet an muskelschwund das heißt es
steht ein starker olaf scholz da und ein
geschwächter armin laschet und ich will
mal ich bin ja schon ein bisschen älter
und erinnere mich an zeiten als die wahl
welt noch sozusagen in ordnung war da
gab es schwarz gelb und rot grün und
wenn man mal diese beiden bündnisse
vergleich das rot grün deutlich stärker
als schwarz-gelb das ist auch ein
ergebnis dieses wahlabends das heißt
wenn ich jetzt olaf scholz wäre und
müsste mein lieblings bündnis rot-grün
es weit vor meinem nicht zu meinem einem
gegnerischen bündnis schwarz gelb dann
würde ich daraus noch mehr vorbei
ableiten als jetzt da irgendwie demütig
um mitstreiter zu werben und das schon
ganz interessant der ball liegt im
prinzip im feld von robert habeck und
von christian lindner und da die beiden
miteinander gut können wie man hört wenn
die kameras aus sind verstehen die sich
eigentlich ganz gut ist diese achse
sozusagen eine sehr spannende für die
zukunft ich bleibe aber bei meiner these
ich glaube wir laufen und eine neue
große koalition das bezog kompliziert
diese dreier bündnisse zu schmieden es
gibt soviel ausschlusskriterien wird
jetzt verhandelt und geredet und alle
themenfelder durchgegangen und keine
kompromisse und faule kompromisse und
dann ist auf und runter diskutiert und
am ende wird ein gespinst an die wand
gemalt und dieses gespenst heisst
neuwahlen wir kriegen leider keine kein
regierungsbündnis zustande dann müssen
die deutschen leider noch mal wählen
wenn die so dämlich gewählt haben müssen
wir eben noch mal wählen die cdu wird
dann sagen oder die oma dann sagen
womöglich mit einem anderen kandidaten
kleineren klammern und das wird dann
keiner so richtig wollen und dann wird
irgendjemand sagen
dann lass uns doch die große koalition
fortsetzen nun mit einem roten kanzler
es wird die kann dieses ergebnis ist die
große koalition mit dem kanzler olaf
scholz und dem vizekanzler armin laschet
und soll ich euch was sagen das haben
die deutschen gewählt das ist auch eine
aussage dieses wahlergebnisses mehr hat
gerade jemand der letzte überlebende
anhänger der großen koalition gesimst
und er hat gesagt dass doch ein klares
votum für schwarz-rot was sollte es
gerangel und das ist auch ein teil der
inneren wahrheit des amtes nur niemand
wahrhaben will weil es niemand will und
deshalb redet auch keiner drüber außer
ich
[Musik]